on faire un petit tour de
la
h on aimerait faire un tour de la ville
de un petit peu plus bas aux environs de
pied c'est
bon c'est
bon al pas mal comme ça
ouais au milieu de
No
ce lotissement là est joli là le
c'est quand Mme vraiment propre par
rapport aux aut
ou les déchs sontign
derrière jus
là
passer pour moi
aussi de personnes au
[Rires]
[Musique]
Milie summer activity
tour dans sens ok Boni ouis parfa OK
we go going back to the other and then
stop at the and do it again the
camera
stop
[Rires]
[Musique]
ok on a
fin
1543 tric helicopter over
the sou of the sou of the airport
from the
installation report to
take
traf circuation
pour0
OK